[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens ils sont un peu
chers je trouve c'est tout le reste ça
va
ouais bah y'en a beaucoup ces fréquences
et il y en a partout il faudra qu'ils
soient là toute la nuit
aussi je serai bien ou du moins
certaines lignes mais ça se trouve c'est
ans est mis en place
je voterai bonbons se croire au dessus
soit frangin
moreau de peter pan tout le monde soit
et les canaux d'après ça je le reconnais
je connais je pense toutes les stations
de métro les anciennes par les nouvelles
mais pratiquement tout est votre elle en
pense quoi
mon frère les cocos sabich je ne rajoute
pas je ne veux pas de bible ni des bus
ni métro supplémentaires ce qui fait que
la rue pointe on est les uns sur les
autres et votre sol en pense quoi
je suis fille unique mais pourrait
prendre sa voiture des transports voilà
tout seul je voterai il en pense quoi
mon frère où il prend toujours des
transports en commun ce toujours ces
moments forts ainsi je pense au maillage
du métro je trouve ça génial
est ce qu'on peut se passer n'importe où
sans avoir besoin de justement de sa
voiture et pas très allants pense quoi
pareil c'est vrai qu'on le prend de
temps en temps et que c'est eux sa
demande
[Rires]
il ya un manque d'organisation total ont
surtout ses fonds propres
l'allemand pas propre et c'est très cher
pour ce que c'est votre est il en pense
quoi
mon frère mon frère ah ouais alors c'est
qui j'avais parlé de francs maçons de
merde
[Musique]